welcome everyone this is part seven in
our series on supervised sentiment
analysis the focus of this screencast is
on feature representation of data there
really two things i'd like to do first
just explore some ideas for effective
feature representation in the context of
sentiment analysis and second cover some
of the core technical concepts that
surround feature representation that you
do well to have in mind as you write new
feature functions and optimize
models let's begin in a familiar place
which is engram feature functions to
this point in the series of screencasts
i've been just focusing on unigram
feature functions that's also called the
bag of words model and we can easily
generalize that idea to bi-grams and
trigrams and so forth
all of these schemes will be heavily
dependent on the tokenizer that you've
chosen because of course in the end for
every example we represent we are simply
tokenizing that example and then
counting the tokens in that example
this can be combined of course with
pre-processing steps in part two in this
series i covered the pre-processing idea
of neg marking which is essentially to
mark words as they appear in a heuristic
way in the scope of negative morphemes
as a way of indicating that for example
good is positive in normal context but
might become negative when it is in the
scope of a negation like not or never
we would handle that as a pre-processing
step and that would just create more
unigrams that our tokenizer would turn
into tokens and then would be counted by
these feature representation schemes
a hallmark of these feature approaches
is that they create very large very
sparse feature representations you are
going to have a column in your feature
representation for every single word
that appears anywhere in your training
data
and another important thing to keep in
mind about this approach is that by and
large they will fail to directly model
relationships between features unless
you make some special effort to
effectively interact these features
all you'll be doing is studying their
distribution with respect to the class
labels that you have and it's very
unlikely that you'll recover in any deep
way the kind of underlying synonymy of
words like couch and sofa for example
and this is a shortcoming that we might
want to address as we move into
distributed representations of examples
and deep learning
so for a first technical concept i would
like to just distinguish between feature
functions and features and to do this
i've just got a fully worked out example
here using tools from scikit-learn that
i think will make the importance of this
this distinction really clear and
concrete so in cell 1 i've just loaded a
bunch of libraries in cell 2 i've got my
standard kind of lazy unigrams feature
function which is taking in a string
text down casing it and then simply
splitting on white space and then the
counter here is just turning that into
account dictionary mapping each token to
the number of times it appears in this
example according to our tokenizer
that'll be fine for now in cell 3 i have
a tiny little corpus that has just two
words a and b
in cell 4 i create a list of
dictionaries by calling unigram spy on
each of the texts in my corpus here so
that gives me a list of count
dictionaries
in five i use a dict vectorizer as
covered in a previous screencast and
what that's going to do is when i call
fit transform on my list of feature
dictionaries it will turn it into a
matrix which is the input that all of
these scikit machine learning models
expect for their training data and in
cell 7 i've just given you what i hope
is a pretty intuitive view of that
design matrix underlyingly it's just a
numpy array but if we use pandas we can
see that the columns here correspond to
the names of each one of the features
because we have just two word types in
our corpus there are two columns a and b
and each of the rows corresponds to an
example from our corpus and so you can
see that our first example has been
reduced to a representation that has
three in its first dimension and zero in
its second corresponding to the fact
that it has three a's and no b's
example two a a b is represented as a
two in the first column and a one in the
second column
and so forth so that's a first
distinction we have this feature
function here which is like a factory
and depending on the data that come in
for our corpus we're going to get very
different features which correspond to
each one of the columns in this feature
representation matrix
let's continue this a little bit and
think about how this actually interacts
with the optimization process so in cell
7 here i've just repeated that previous
matrix for reference
in cell 8 i have the class labels for
our four examples and you can see there
are three distinct classes c1 c2 and c3
i set up a logistic regression model
although that's not especially important
it's just a useful illustration
and i call fit on my pair xy that is my
feature representations and my labels
and that's the optimization process as
part of that and for a convention for
scikit the optimization process creates
this new attribute co-f underscore and
this new attribute classes underscore
these co co-f here these are the weights
that we learned as part of the
optimization process and of course
classes corresponds to the classes that
inferred from the label y that we input
and here i'm just using a panda's data
frame again to try to make this
intuitive it's really just a numpy array
this co-f object here but you can see
that the resulting matrix has a row for
each one of our classes and a column for
each one of our features
and that's a useful reminder that what
the optimization process for models like
this is actually doing
is learning a weight that associates
class feature name pairs
with a weight right so it's not just
that we learn individual weights for
features but rather we learn them with
respect to each one of the classes and
that's a hallmark of optimization for
multi-class models like this one
and then in cell 12 i've just shown you
that you can actually use the co-f and
this other bias term inter-score
intercept underscore
to recreate the predictions of the model
all you're doing is multiplying examples
by those coefficients and adding in the
bias term and this matrix here is
identical to what you get inside if you
simply directly call predict prabha for
predict probabilities on your examples
let's turn back to what we're trying to
do to create good models having those
ideas in mind so let's just cover a few
other ideas for hand-built feature
functions that i think could be
effective for sentiment so of course
we'd have lexicon derived features i
earlier showed you a bunch of different
lexicons and that could be used to group
our unigrams so we could have these
feature functions work in conjunction
with a bag of words or bag of engrams
model or we could use them to replace
that model and develop a sparser feature
representation space
we could also do the negation marking
that i mentioned before and we could
generalize that idea so many things in
language take scope in a way that will
affect the semantics of words that are
in their scope so another classical
example behind besides negation is these
modal adverbs like quite possibly or
totally we might have the idea that they
are modulating the extent to which the
speaker is committed to masterpiece or
amazing in this case and keeping track
of that semantic association with simple
underscore marking of some kind might be
useful for giving our model a chance to
see that these unigrams are different
depending on their environment
we could also have length based features
and that's just a useful reminder that
these don't all have to be count
features we could have real valued
features of various kinds and they could
signal something important about the
class label like for example i think
neutral reviews three star reviews tend
to be longer than one in five star
reviews so might as well throw that in
and we can expand that idea of float
value features a little bit more i like
the idea of thwarted expectations which
you might keep track of as the ratio of
positive to negative words in a sentence
uh the idea being that very often if
that ratio is exaggerated it's telling
you the opposite story that you might
expect about the overall sentiment many
many positive words stacked up together
might actually be preparing you for a
negative assessment and the reverse
but the important thing about this
feature is that it wouldn't decide for
you what these ratios mean you would
just hope that it was a useful signal
that your model might pick up on as part
of optimization to figure out how to
make use of the information
and then finally we could do things
various kinds of ad hoc feature
functions to try to capture the fact
that many uses of language are
non-literal and might be signaling
exactly the opposite of what they seem
to do on their surface like not exactly
a masterpiece is probably a pretty
negative review
it was like 50 hours long is not saying
that it was actually 50 hours long but
rather with hyperbole indicating that it
was much too long or something like that
and the best movie in the history of the
universe could be a
ringing endorsement but it could just as
easily be a bit of sarcasm
capturing those kind of subtle
distinctions is of course much more
difficult but the handle feature
functions that you write where you could
try to capture it and if they have a
positive effect then
maybe you've made some real progress
and that's a good transition point to
this topic of assessing individual
feature functions as you can see the
philosophy in this mode of work is that
you write lots of feature functions and
kind of see how well they can do at
improving your model overall
you might end up with a very large model
with many correlated features and that
might lead you to want to do some
feature selection to weed out the ones
that are not contributing in a positive
way
now scikit-learn has a whole library for
doing this called feature selection and
it offers lots of functions that will
let you assess how much information your
feature functions contain with respect
to the labels for your classification
problem so this is very powerful and i
encourage you to use them but you should
be a little bit cautious
take care when assessing feature
functions individually because
correlations between those features will
make the assessments very hard to
interpret
the problem here is that your model is
holistically thinking about how all
these features relate to your class
label and figuring out how to optimize
weights on that basis whereas the
feature function methods many of them
just look at individual features and how
they relate to the class labels so
you're losing all that correlational
context
and to make that a little concrete i
just cooked up an example here an
idealized one that shows how you could
be misled so i have three features x1 x2
and x3 and a simple binary
classification problem and i use the
chi-square test from feature selection
to kind of assess how important each one
of these features is with respect to
this classification problem
and what i found is that intuitively it
looks like x1 and x2 are really powerful
features
and that might lead me to think well
i'll drop the third feature and include
just one and two in my model
so far so good however if we thoroughly
explore this space what we find is that
in truth a simple linear model performs
best with just feature x1 and actually
including x2 hurts the model despite the
fact that it has this positive feature
importance value so what we really ought
to be doing is using just this single
feature but these methods can't tell us
that and even a positive
feature selection value might actually
be something that's at odds with what
we're trying to do with our model as
this example shows
so ideally what you would do is consider
more holistic assessment methods which
scikit also offers this would be things
like systematically removing or
perturbing feature values in the context
of the full model that you're optimizing
and comparing performance across those
models this is much more expensive
because you're optimizing many many
models so it might be prohibitive for
some classes of models that you're
exploring but if you can do it this will
be more reliable
however if this is impossible it might
still be productive to do some feature
selection using simpler methods you
should just be aware that you might be
doing something that's not optimal for
the actual optimization problem that
you've posed
okay in the final section of this
screencast is a kind of transition into
the world of deep learning i've called
this distributed representations as
features this is a very different mode
for thinking about representing examples
what we do in this case is take our
token stream as before but instead of
writing a lot of hand-built feature
functions we simply look up each one of
those tokens in some embedding that we
have for example it could be an
embedding that you created in the first
unit of this course
or it could be a glove embedding or a
static embedding that you derived from
vert representations and so forth and so
on the important thing is that each
token is now represented by a vector
and that could be a powerful idea
because in representing each of these
words as vectors we are now
capturing the relationships between
those tokens we might now have a hope of
seeing that sofa and couch are actually
similar features in general and not just
with respect to the class labels that we
have
so that's the idea why this might be
powerful so we take all those vectors
and look them up however for all these
classifier models we need a fixed
dimensional representation to feed into
the actual classifier unit so we're
going to have to combine those vectors
in some way and the simplest thing you
could do is combine them via some
function like sum or mean right
so i would take all these things for
example and take their average and that
would give me another fixed dimensional
representation no matter how many tokens
are in each one of the examples
and that average vector would be the
input to the classifier
so if each one of these vectors has
dimension 300 then so too does the
feature representation of my entire
example and now i now have a classifier
which which is processing feature
representations that have 300 columns
each dimension in the underlying
embedding space now corresponds to a
feature
and that's the basis for optimization
and i'd say an eye-opening thing about
this class of models is despite them
being very compact you know 300
dimensions versus 20 000 that you might
have from a bag of words model they turn
out to be very powerful
and this final slide here just shows you
how to implement those using tools and
other utilities for our course
so i'm going to use glove and i'm going
to use the 300 dimensional glove space
which is included in your data
distribution
in four and five here we just write
simple feature functions and the
hallmark of these is that they are
simply looking up words in the embedding
and then combining them via whatever
function the user specifies so the
output of this is directly a vector
representation of each example
in cell six we set up a logistic
regression as before of course it could
be a much fancier model but logistic
regression will do
and then we use ssd experiment almost
exactly as before the one change we need
to remember to make when operating in
this mode is to set the flag vectorize
equals false
we already have each example represented
as a vector so we do not need to pass it
through that whole process of using a
dict vectorizer to turn count
dictionaries into vectors
and as i said before these turn out to
be quite good models despite their
compactness and the final thing i'll say
is that this model is a nice transition
into the recurrent neural networks that
we'll study in the final screencast for
this unit which essentially generalized
this idea by learning an interesting
combination function for all the vectors
for each of the individual tokens
you